et si le nautisme était le moteur du
développement touristique en martinique
la martinique boat show
mais sur ce salon où sont exposés les
derniers modèles de bateaux à moteur
pour valoriser la filière
de nombreux professionnels tels que des
loueurs des motoristes ou encore des
équipementiers viennent ici montrer leur
savoir faire auprès des utilisateurs de
la mer j'ai trouvé un peu de tout ce que
je recherchais des idées des contacts
avec les professionnels
un peu de tout quoi et moi je dis que
c'est une très bonne initiative
une initiative ouverte aux demandeurs
d'emploi le secteur du nautisme serait
temps plein développement
les intéressés ce salon pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est une opportunité de me
rapprocher des chefs d'entreprise ou des
entreprises qui ont besoin de personnes
qualifiées ce secteur on voit bien que
c'est de me dire en pleine mutation
après une évolution aussi bien quelqu'un
que les formations dans le domaine de la
mécanique de l'électricité de la soudure
l'opportunité de mettre ses compétences
à l'ensemble de le proposer à des chefs
d'entreprise pour faire vivre cette
filière il faudra la structure et
dynamiser le marché local pourrait bien
avoir un impact sur l'ensemble de l'arc
caribéen
on a le directeur général boston whaler
qui est un fabricant de bateaux qui
s'appuie sur son et qui est venu visiter
ce salon pour voir quels étaient les
capacités de développement pour sa
marque et qui qui veut s'appuyer sur la
martinique pour développer la
distribution de ces bateaux à l'étranger
on a le patron d'une vie drink et qui
est venu
on a le patron de passes timo france
kaki un fabricant d'accastillage pour
les bateaux qui est venu voir f
effectivement aussi qu'elle était si on
venu prendre la température si vous
voulez pour s'appuyer sur la martinique
pour développer les marchés kyle d'ici
deux ans ce rendez vous devrait rentrer
dans le parcours des salons nautiques
internationaux
c'est en tout cas leur objectif pour
espérer attirer de nombreux touristes
fortunés